blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
davidpakman so I want to start today
with one of the two big areas where
there is a particularly high amount of
disinformation spreading right now now
earlier in the week we talked about one
such area and that's coveted in vaccines
the I don't even know what to call it
it's almost like calling calling it The
launch seems weird it's almost like a
product but the Breakthrough of the
Omicron variant into the news which
started on the day after Thanksgiving
last week and led to two very very shaky
days in the stock market that's one
topic that has lent itself to
significant disinformation right-wing
media and Republicans going crazy with
false claims about the variant itself
false claims about covid fall false
claims about vaccines etc etc we covered
that Monday we covered it to some extent
yesterday Tuesday the other area that is
being victimized by disinformation from
the right at this point in time
is the economy and by the economy that
includes the supply chain stuff
employment
inflation and a few other areas that's
another area of significant
disinformation with such esteemed
talking points from the right as
inflation is never going to end and it's
going to destroy the economy nobody
wants to work anymore because of
unemployment and there's no workers and
the job situation is a disaster
etc etc you guys have heard a lot of
these uh talking points oh and also
there's no uh chinese-made tchotchkes
for Christmas on the shelves thanks to
Joe Biden okay so those are the kind of
General topics
when we actually look at the economic
data that is generally accepted as
signaling how the economy is doing now
I'll get back to that because that's not
a trivial matter there are measures we
generally accept to to tell us about the
economy we could say these are the wrong
measures but we're going to get back to
that when you look at those measures
things actually look okay
a few new as we are now into December a
few new bullet points of data that were
released today
initial jobless claims meaning new
unemployment claims fell to their lowest
level last month November since November
of 1969 on What's called the seasonally
adjusted basis okay that's the the week
before Thanksgiving
um now unadjusted numbers increase then
this is an important thing to understand
there were 199 000 new unemployment
claims during the week ending November
20th the week before Thanksgiving
now those have been what's called
seasonally adjusted this is an accepted
method for getting what we might call a
truer number which controls for the
layoff patterns that are expected based
on the time of year that it is there are
Industries including retail
Agriculture and others which have
seasonal patterns for hiring and laying
people off and they don't really
represent a true hire or layoff in some
sense so there's this process called
adjustment now if you don't adjust the
numbers claims actually did go up a
little bit by 18 000 to almost 259 000
that week before Thanksgiving but the
general picture is that these are very
low numbers for new unemployment claims
that's one side of the equation it
actually looks pretty good the labor
department actually expected many more
people to apply for unemployment
benefits for the first time in that week
before Thanksgiving they anticipated
seventy thousand more it was actually
only eighteen thousand more and that's a
good thing by this metric okay now
there's a question as to whether you
know I said the lowest in 52 years we
have changed a number of things over
that 52-year period And so there's a
legitimate question as to are we really
comparing apples to apples when we
compare 2021 to 1969 or some period in
between because there have been changes
in that interim period for example some
states have made it harder to get
unemployment particularly since the
Great Recession of 2008-2009 so that
would reduce the number who even apply
because they know it's harder to
actually get the benefits that's that's
fair that could be a factor on the other
hand
since the start of the pandemic more
people are aware that such benefits
could be made available to them so that
would be a factor that compared to the
70s and 80s for example makes more
people apply generally speaking you take
a very top-line look new unemployment
claims are very very low on an
unadjusted basis on an adjusted basis
dating back uh five decades really
pieces of six decades all the way back
to 1969 so that's one thing what about
job creation on the other side of
unemployment is job creation well
private payrolls went up by 534 000 in
November
that's quite a bit better than the Dow
Jones expectation of 506 000 new jobs
expected was 506 actual was 534.
um Leisure and Hospitality saw again
um companies with more than 500
employees saw a big gain companies with
over a thousand employees saw an even
bigger proportional gain and so that's
all pretty good by the standards that we
use so the question marks now are what
happens with Omicron and to what degree
does that impact the economy at least in
the U.S and this is an economic
statement I'm making not a public health
statement there does not seem to be much
if any appetite for anything that would
approximate a shutdown or a lockdown of
any kind
now whether it will make sense from a
public health standpoint first we need
to know how serious Omicron is we still
don't but that's a public health
question dealing with this as an
economic question it doesn't seem like
there's really much appetite for that
what happens with supply chain
um and are these even good metrics and
that's something that is a different
question you know there are systemic
problems with the economy that I talk
about all the time that I know many of
you are aware of which aren't part of
this analysis when we look at new
unemployment claims or job creation or
whatever we aren't talking about wage
growth we're not talking about the
reality that the minimum wage in most of
the United States
is not a living wage as defined by can
you even get a basic two-bedroom
apartment in the place where you are
employed at the minimum wage those are
systemic problems that still exist and
there's no question that the metrics we
use fall woefully short that being said
the right accepts these metrics and so
on their own terms it's very difficult
to argue that we have a bad economy
right now we haven't solved not
everybody has Health Care
that doesn't change but by the standards
the right accepts things are actually
looking okay and it's important to
understand that when you hear they're
despairing talking points on Fox News
and elsewhere
um I got a ton of emails over the
weekend
um and yesterday and today saying David
you're not gonna cover the Chris Cuomo
thing because you're a Democrat and he's
a Democrat and you run interference for
CNN and
um have you ever seen this show before
because that's a number one I'm not a
Democrat number two I don't care about
the Democratic party number three I
don't even watch corporate media with
the exception of clips that are sent to
me for things I might cover on the show
I don't really care what's happening I
don't care about CNN I don't care about
running interference for CNN I don't
know if Chris Cuomo is a Democrat I know
his brother the former Governor of of
New York is a Democrat is Chris Cuomo a
Democrat maybe maybe I don't care it
makes no difference to me and the Chris
Cuomo story is a very uh important media
story
and the story is by the way as we
already talked about on yesterday's
bonus show the story is that while
Andrew Cuomo the former Governor of New
York was being hit with allegation after
allegation of sexual assault Chris Cuomo
CNN anchor was using his media sources
to find information about the accusers
and was giving that information to a top
aide for Andrew Cuomo
um and sort of helping to craft a
response a public response to the
allegations now of course you would
expect if you have a brother
who knows about how things play in media
and has access you would expect that
he's going to try to help you the
question of course is about the
appropriateness of him being on air at
all on CNN
on air on CNN sometimes interviewing his
brother and CNN has now suspended Chris
Cuomo indefinitely and it is obviously
the right decision wait sir what are
you're not defend guys I don't care I
don't care about the partisan stuff I
don't even necessarily uh uh see this as
that this is just completely
inappropriate New York Times article
explains CNN suspends Chris Cuomo after
new details on help he gave his brother
the cable news Network's top-rated
anchor was an intimate advisor to Andrew
Cuomo in the last 18 months of his
governorship
the CNN anchor Chris Cuomo suspended
indefinitely by the network yesterday
after new details emerged about his
efforts to assist Andrew Cuomo his
brother as he faced the Cascade of
sexual harassment accusations Cuomo
previously apologized for advising
Andrew Cuomo's senior political aides a
breach of traditional barriers between
journalists and lawmakers but thousands
of pages of evidence released Monday by
the New York AG revealed that the
Anchor's role was more intimate and
involved than previously known
um Mr Cuomo's entanglement with the last
18 months of his brother's governorship
has proved a slow-moving headache for
CNN which has stood by its top-rated
anchor even as a drip of uncomfortable
Revelations raised questions about the
Network's adherence to journalistic
standards Jeff Zucker CNN's president
supported Cuomo for months declining to
discipline him even after reports showed
he was in strategy sessions with his
brother's political team a breach of
basic repertorial conduct earlier this
year the network floated the idea that
he could take a temporary leave if he
really wanted to focus formally on
helping Andrew Cuomo but now a very
harsh set of facts came out
um we talked a little bit about this on
the bonus show in scores of emails and
text messages between Chris Cuomo and
his brother's Inner Circle he repeatedly
offered advice let me help you with prep
he texted his senior aide he made
efforts to track down the status of
pending articles about the sexual
assault allegations at what harassment
allegations at one point uh the
governor's former top aide Melissa
DeRosa asked the anchor if he could
check his sources on a rumor that
Politico was working on a story with
more accusations on it Chris Cuomo
responded
also includes a report the report
includes a text from Cuomo to the
advisor DeRosa sent a few days after a
woman Anna Ruck told the New York Times
that Cuomo made an unwanted Advance
toward her at a wedding I have a lead on
the wedding girl Chris Cuomo wrote in
the text
um Chris Cuomo later told investigators
he heard from a friend that quote maybe
she had been put up to it so listen this
is obviously the correct decision from
CNN you're not going to find me
defending any of these actions this is
completely inappropriate there are
broader questions in terms of you know
the interviews that Chris Cuomo would do
with Andrew Cuomo which were basically
softball interviews and sometimes there
would be sort of like
okay now I gotta ask you a real question
even though you're my brother I gotta
ask you a serious question it's just all
not really journalism
um and that was a problem from day one
and this is just completely over the top
inappropriate so if you're surprised
that this is the position I'm taking I
guess you don't know me you don't know
my show but I don't know how at this
point
Chris Cuomo can really be on CNN in a
serious incredible way that doesn't mean
his career is over I mean look at Brian
Williams making up War Stories and then
goes away for a while and just comes
back look at Jeffrey tuben caught
masturbating on a zoom meeting and he
had to be removed from the air and he's
quietly back and so it it's not over for
Chris Cuomo but this is completely
inappropriate and if there's any
criticism here it's CNN didn't act
quickly enough although this is
obviously the right decision if you
disagree let me know find me on Twitter
at dpacman and tell me as a reminder we
are now under two weeks from the next
David packman show viewer Town Hall all
are welcome member or not all are
welcome to participate it will be
December 14th at 6 PM eastern time it
will be live only on the Pac-Man Live
YouTube channel that's the second
YouTube channel
um make sure you're subscribed there
it's free and if you want a better shot
of getting on with me sign up at
joinpakman.com as our members do get
priority but it is open to all uh
looking very much forward to it we'll
take a quick break and be back right
after this
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the David packman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app I just
listened to this is your mind on Plants
by the great Michael pollen super
interesting the history of caffeine and
so many other things blinkist has you
covered on podcast too blinkist takes
long episodes of popular podcasts and
distills them into audio you can listen
to in 15 minutes with blinkist you can
become knowledgeable about so many
different things you can have
conversations with people about more
topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded tribe link is for free and
get 25 off a subscription go to
blinkist.com
davidpackman the link is down below
all right a new Challenger has entered
the Pennsylvania Senate race and it is
television Dr Mehmet Oz known for being
a purveyor of quack cures and
pseudoscience can't even really call
them treatments really shouldn't even
call them cures uh we're going to get to
that
um television Dr Mehmet Oz is running
for Senate in Pennsylvania as a
Republican and he's a complete disgrace
to the medical field and if he were
Senator it would be yet another complete
disgrace to this country but Trump won
so Dr Oz could certainly win there is a
good candidate in that race and it's a
really important race uh the good
candidate is John fetterman uh
lieutenant governor of Pennsylvania
um and now we have a really bad
candidate Dr Oz has promoted all sorts
of quack cures for years he's the
opposite of what we need in power and
here is his big announcement that he is
running
my parents came to America to find a
better life and they did I attended
great universities raised a family and
became a successful surgeon I invented a
heart valve that saves thousands of
lives then I started a TV show The
Advocate for you taking control of your
health
and took on the medical establishment to
argue against costly drugs and
skyrocketing medical bills but covid has
shown us that our system is broken we
lost too many lives too many jobs and
too many opportunities because
Washington got it wrong they took away
our freedom without making us safer and
tried to kill our spirit and our dignity
as a heart surgeon I know how precious
life is Pennsylvania needs a
conservative who will put America first
one who can reignite our divine spark
bravely fight for freedom and tell it
like it is that's why I'm running for
said it I'm Dr Oz and I approve this
message this is a major Senate race in
2022 in Pennsylvania
this Senate race could decide who
controls the senate in the next term
Democrats or Republicans it's going to
be an open seat the incumbent Republican
senator Pat Toomey has said he's not
running for reelection Joe Biden won
Pennsylvania in 2020 but Pennsylvania is
really a state that particularly on
Senate can can go either way even on
presidential it's not a typically a big
win for one side or the other it's a
fight and Dr Oz is exactly the type of
celebrity that Republicans would love to
vote for and he's truly horrible uh he
has done a lot of horrible things on his
show just as some examples he held a
debate about gay reparative therapy as
if there's a legitimate conversation
about it this is like when a network
says we're going to debate climate
change
and they bring on someone who
understands and states the facts and
someone else who just presents a
completely wacky conspiracy View and
presents them as if they are even Dr Oz
did the same thing with gay reparative
therapy Dr Oz promoted green coffee bean
extract for weight loss
there are no weight loss benefits to
green coffee bean extract it's one of
these
purported things that has since been
admitted to being bogus he promoted the
use of hydroxychloroquine to treat covid
on multiple Fox News broadcasts and of
course as many of you know
um I listed hydroxychloroquine back at
that time along with seven or eight
other things that were being looked at
as does this work the FDA revoked an eua
for hydroxychloroquine saying there was
no reason to believe that it was
effective against covid-19 he has been
pushing remember he's an actual this is
not like you know uh when what oh doctor
but it's not a medical doctor so you've
got a this is a medical doctor and he
still pushes nonsense uh Dr Oz
supportive of Homeopathy which is just
completely debunked I know some people
in the audience get mad at me guys it's
totally debunked there's often no active
ingredients in it in measurable
quantities it has been determined that
Homeopathy cannot treat or cure any
condition of any kind period it's just
it's nothing okay I'm sorry guys it's
just nothing uh Dr Oz promoted energy
therapies of different kinds
he's expressed support for Faith healing
he is kowtowed to psychic communication
and much more Dr Oz has repeatedly
claimed that raspberry
oh man he has claimed that raspberry
ketones are the number one miracle in a
bottle to burn your fat
he has said astrological signs May
reveal a great deal about your health
and saying that for centuries we've used
astrological signs to examine our
personalities and how we interact but
there may be much to be revealed about
our health as well that's not true
that's that's a lie
um Dr Oz said that most countries
require genetically modified foods to be
specially labeled sort of implying that
it's because GMOs are unsafe now the
reality is that most countries do not
require such labels
GMO foods have been studied and have
found to be safe now the issue of
pesticides is often intermingled with
GMO pesticides are a different story but
GMOs have been studied and there's no
evidence that they are unsafe for human
consumption there's something called
umcalobo I don't even know if I'm
pronouncing that correctly it's a root
extract and he says that it's been
incredibly effective at relieving cold
symptoms even though that's not true
there are not reliable studies on that
and then remember when he said that you
know what if we open schools
we might have two to three percent
mortality but that would be a good trade
what remember this from April of 2020 on
the Sean Hannity program Dr Oz help us
well first we need our mojo back let's
start with things that are really
critical to the nation where we think we
might build open without getting into a
lot of trouble I tell you schools are a
very appetizing opportunity uh I just
saw a nice piece in the Lancer arguing
that the opening of schools may only
cost us two to three percent in terms of
total mortality and you know that's any
life is a life loss but to get every
child back into a school where they're
safely being educated being fed uh and
making the most out of their lives with
a theoretical risk in the backside it
might be a trade-off some folks would
consider wow and I mean that's just
completely Bonkers first of all once
schools opened we saw that it was insane
spread and once months later obviously
schools opened and it was just like
immediately this entire class has to
quarantine tip Florida Educators dying
all over I mean just crazy two to three
percent of mortality is a trade-off that
we might make so you know there was a
point where we would never imagine that
a guy like this would have a shot
except Donald Trump won and Dr Oz could
clearly win Dr Oz could be the person
who takes the Senate from Democrats in
2022. now fortunately we have a great
option and that's John fetterman running
in Pennsylvania this isn't an
endorsement but I like fetterman we have
good options is the point Pat toomey's
retiring Republican Senators retiring
and it's not like it's Dr Oz or nobody
we have at minimum John fetterman I know
there are other candidates running on
both the Democratic and Republican sides
there will be primaries to choose who
ultimately makes it to the general
election in November now only 11 months
away guys it's it's the midterms we're
in the midterms already
um and it would be an absolute disaster
if Dr Oz were to win let's next look at
the welcome with open arms that Dr Oz
received on Fox News over the last 24 to
48 hours okay so Dr Oz a promoter of
various quack cures Homeopathy raspberry
ketones green coffee bean extract uh
Faith healing
um okay energy healing and all these
different things he is running for
Senate as a republican in Pennsylvania
there's an opponent of his who's a great
choice John fetterman we've talked about
that we've talked about his platform and
his campaign a little bit
um he is getting Dr Oz is getting the
heroes welcome on Fox News probably not
coming as a surprise to most of you but
softball interview after softball
interview over the last 24 hours on a
whole bunch of different shows let's
start with uh Dr Oz's interview with
Sean Hannity last night I could tell you
in a minute what my political philosophy
is but rather than me tell you mine what
is yours right
well I'll tell you one thing for sure
any government that's large enough to
give you everything is powerful enough
to take it all away so I don't want that
that is that is a hell of a republican
talking but he knows the talking points
he has them prepared and this is the
Right audience for them that's for sure
liberty and freedom and that to me means
limited government we can do it better
than folks very far away from us who
don't know our local problems the more
we can be it's local the more we can
trust the people in our communities the
better off we are it's funny because you
know a lot of the quack cures that he
has promoted on his show
his small government perspective would
be maybe that stuff shouldn't even be
regulated I don't like you know maybe it
should just be well if Dr Oz promoted
this that's the same as FDA approval I'm
not saying he said that but this
thinking of as little government as
possible pushes you in that direction
let's continue I believe in energy
Independence that's a big deal here in
Pennsylvania but we don't as a nation
want to be begging other countries like
we're starting to do to change what
they're doing with energy because you
know we're in the hawk I believe in
capitalism that which means lower taxes
and regulations so people can really
compete and I respect the Constitution
I've brilliantly written document that I
think should be honored on the bench and
sometimes isn't we have free market
solutions that guys he has this I mean
this is actually it's a minute and he
hits like every Republican talking point
here and Healthcare I'll tell you this
is my specialty area and I spent my life
studying this where you can protect
against pre-existing conditions and use
free market solutions to healthcare that
makes it affordable accessible for
everybody you imagine he spent his life
studying Health Care
and he has promoted green coffee bean
extract raspberry ketones and all that
other stuff it's crazy but he knows the
talking points he has been well trained
um in this next clip on Fox and Friends
he warns against mixing politics and
medicine can you imagine
when you mix politics and Medicine you
get politics right what we witnessed not
just with uh had actually chloroquine
but many other solutions that have been
offered subsequently is that there's a
single perspective that's allowed to get
vaccinated listen I think one of the
greatest accomplishments of America is
that we gave the world the MRNA vaccines
through president Trump's operational
warp speed I'm so happy that we were
able to do that and I got vaccinated and
I believe in vaccines I don't believe in
mandates
it's so funny when he says you know the
hydroxychloroquine became politicized
dude you were on TV promoting it absent
actual medical evidence that it did
anything for covid and subsequently its
authorization for emergency use was
revoked by the FDA it's you know he he
has the Republican talking points down
he also has Republican projection down
perfectly
um here's another one where he uh he's
getting into we got to stop canceling
and and I mean he you got to hand it to
him he came in prepared with all of the
bullet points that Republicans are
currently using I'm going to serve
America in this time of need the best of
my ability we need better Solutions
they're out there we ought to stop
shaming and silencing and bullying and
canceling people with ideas that are
different than ours especially when
they're good ideas right so that play
out plenty in covid and I got to say in
medicine when you cannot say what you
see people die so we ought to be able to
do at least that I'm going to serve I
mean it's just it's it's all backwards
but this is exact this is why his
candidacy has the potential to work
absent any actual policy just stating
these vague principles that are
abandoned when they don't coincide with
your beliefs we should be allowed to say
things when there's an idea about
medicine well you talked about
hydroxychloroquine and it was debunked
well but they shouldn't have canceled
you can't cancel can't but but it was a
bad idea
it it did not work
um here he is explaining why he's
running here's my pledge my promise to
everybody I want to be your public
servant yeah and every choice I make
will be serving the citizens of
Pennsylvania and the United States and
none of them will serve the special
interests in Washington many who have
been to war with for most of my career
let's reinvigorate America I think he
means at war with being being to war
with them it actually means something
different but I think he means he's been
against them and let's see that Divine
spark in each other because it's there
dear God
um it's weird he even mispronounces
Pennsylvania as Pennsylvania like Trump
does like every aspect of this is very
very trumpy here's a clip that's kind of
messed up the video is weird but you can
hear him say a little bit about
immigration like we actually this is the
only thing I've heard him say that
approximates policy
immigration is a big problem for a
couple reasons for one we're subsidizing
cartels by the way he's running in
Pennsylvania speaking of immigration
they're involved in human trafficking I
mentioned you're bringing opiates across
the border but lots of other issues as
well I think president Trump was right
people should wait on Mexican side of
the Border if they're coming across
illegally let's deal with all the issues
there and not put law enforcement in an
impossible predicament where they're
forced now people on this country to
chase them down when we know they're not
coming yeah you know and of course
what's being ignored when we don't even
have to it's disgusting me uh what's
being ignored is they they also apply
that to people seeking Asylum they say
well they should seek asylum in Mexico
at an office like well a lot of times
people seeking Asylum are in dire and
dangerous situations so that's why
they're coming over and at the border
saying I am seeking Asylum it's a
complicated issue I'm not pretending
it's not but Dr Oz presenting us the
same simplistic analysis that uh Donald
Trump presented so welcomed with open
arms by right wing media we've got to be
very careful this guy has a real shot
not only at winning but it being the
seat that decides whether Democrats or
Republicans control the Senate starting
in January of 2023. we'll have more of
this on our Instagram find us on
Instagram at davidpackman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
in the uh aftermath of both the Kyle
Rittenhouse trial and the trial over the
killing of Ahmad Arbury now the gileen
Maxwell trial has started and this is
the trial over uh jilayan Maxwell
colloquially believed to be sort of like
the fixer for much of the sexual assault
that the late Jeffrey Epstein was
involved in uh Julian Maxwell both his
girlfriend and also sort of uh you know
that a lot of this is allegations that
that are being explored but believed to
be accused of being
um someone who helped groom and get uh
women into this kind of um perverse
alleged system of abuse that Epstein
perpetuated and um in the last few days
folks including like Lauren bobert the
Republican congresswoman who's vile I
mean just vile disgusting woman
made a big deal of saying the left is
worried about this trial because a lot
of leftists are going to be exposed for
maybe being involved with Jeffrey
Epstein
um well yesterday Jeffrey Epstein's
former airplane pilot testified and
named Donald Trump as a passenger on
Epstein's what was sometimes called
shockingly the Lolita Express also
naming Bill Clinton the point here is
not that this doesn't hit Democrats and
Republicans but rather that it basically
just involves a powerful men who want to
be around rich people powerful people
and young attractive women quite frankly
and so this is potentially not going to
go well for a lot of different people a
bunch of interesting reports including
this one from Newsweek which says Trump
Clinton among famous Flyers no sex act
seen on Jeffrey Epstein's jet pilate
says
um Jeffrey Epstein's former pilot
testified Tuesday in the sex trafficking
trial of gelane Maxwell saying he never
saw any evidence of sexual activity when
he was flying Epstein's plane
um you know that could be meaningful or
not oftentimes the pilots don't leave
the cockpit during uh during these
flights which are often just a few hours
um the Associated Press reported that
Lawrence Paul vasovsky Jr was Epstein's
pilot for nearly 30 years piloted around
a thousand flights between 91 and 2019.
he said he flew famous people such as
prince Andrew whose association with
Epstein was already known former U.S
President Bill Clinton and Donald Trump
Maxwell has been accused of recruiting
and grooming girls that Epstein was
accused of sexually abusing for at least
10 years starting in 2004 vasovsky said
in the hierarchy of Epstein's World
Maxwell was the number two while Epstein
was the big number one some media
members have called Epstein's plan the
Lolita Express after allegations
surfaced he used it to fly teen girls to
his properties though visotsky says Ah
he stayed in the cockpit for the
majority of the flights he said Epstein
never warned him to stay there and
encouraged him to use the bathroom in
the back which would require him to walk
through the length of the plane when
Maxwell's attorney Christian everdel
asked visosky if he had ever seen sexual
activity or toys on the plane he said
never he also said he had absolutely not
seen any sexual activity with underage
girls on the plane adding he had also
never seen children on the plane who
were not with their parents
uh whenever doll asked about a teenager
who prosecutors say was sexually abused
by Epstein before she became an adult
visoski said he believed she was mature
when he was introduced to her he also
acknowledged that Bill Clinton was a
passenger on a few flights in the 2000s
had piloted planes with Britain's prince
Andrew the late U.S senator John Glenn
and former president Donald Trump and
Bill Clinton more than once more than
once
um so listen uh this is being made out
to be a partisan the right is saying
this was a democratic sexual assault
party plane Bill Clinton
Etc uh some on the left are saying it's
Trump who was really the guy here it's
everybody guys and it's everybody who
was on the planes rep Republicans and
Democrats in terms of sexual assault we
don't know now it should be said and I
want to be really careful how I say it
there have been allegations
made against Epstein and Trump
as a what's the even word as a team I
mean I don't even know what to say
um about what I believe would qualify as
gang rape of a minor that that's an
allegation that has been made
um but charges have been dropped and
there's a lot of complication about it
but we've seen the video of Donald Trump
and Jeffrey Epstein at a party sort of
like evaluating and raiding women who
were dancing based on the video we don't
have any evidence that those women were
underage they all appear to have been of
age but uh my instinct is there's a lot
of people wrapped up with this and
um I don't believe that it is a partisan
thing and we're going to see what comes
out now a lot of people have gotten very
conspiratorial saying whoa on the first
day of shilane Maxwell's trial
Jack Dorsey steps down as CEO of Twitter
there's no evidence whatsoever that the
two things are related
um another one is the day Omicron is
announced the G Lane Maxwell trial
starts actually that's not even true the
trial started Monday Omicron sort of
became National global news on Friday it
does it doesn't even really make sense
um that being said
um without going any further of course
if jelane Maxwell is found dead by
Suicide
I will be wondering about that that
would be very very strange and um
okay yeah I mean you know that's the
email I get most frequently David will
you will you concede that if she Lane
Maxwell takes her own life that it would
be strange yeah yeah I mean it hasn't
happened it's a hypothetical it has not
happened but yes that would be a strange
thing this is bipartisan trouble quite
frankly and it doesn't look like it's
going to stop anytime soon the problems
will not stop for Donald Trump's former
supposed fraud lawyer
Sydney Powell now why do I say supposed
well you guys if you've been following
the story I've been telling you about
this story for a year now Sydney Powell
appeared to be representing Donald Trump
in various of these frivolous voter
fraud
motions and complaints filed to courts
after the 2020 election but when she got
really cuckoo for Cocoa Puffs the White
House put out the Trump the then Trump
White House put out a statement saying
what she's doing she's doing on her own
and then she was banned from the Oval
Office but was reportedly seen there
anyway Etc okay
the latest is that she is now under
federal investigation
um feds are now asking questions about
Sydney Powell and her pro-trump group
now the details are interesting and
you'll see why in a moment The Daily
Beast reports ever since Sydney Powell
spearheaded one of then president
Trump's efforts to nullify the election
she has found herself on the wrong side
of a flurry of potentially ruinous
lawsuits but this is not the only part
of her deepening troubles
for months the federal investigation
running out of Washington DC has been
demanding documents and asking potential
Witnesses about Powell according to
three people familiar with the matter
separately similarly a separate
investigation into Powell's
anti-democratic activities took place in
the Sunshine State earlier this year and
has already produced results and
punished Powell in her far-right group
the federal probe which has not been
previously reported is examining the
finances of defending the Republic an
organization founded by Powell to fund
her lawsuits to overturn the 2020
election according to two of the people
familiar with the matter a grand jury
was impaneled and subpoenas and
documents subpoenas and document
requests have gone out to multiple
individuals as recently as September
defending the Republic's finances have
already prompted an investigation and a
settlement with Florida's charity
regulator they paid a ten thousand
dollar fine
uh in secretly recorded conversations
released by erstwhile Powell Ally Lynn
wood over the last few days former
overstock.com and defending the Republic
CEO Patrick Byrne accused Powell of
pocketing funds from the group in order
to pay for her defense against that
billion dollar defamation suit filed by
Dominion voting systems they haven't
responded to the comments so this is
very very interesting because
this is about the financing of the
non-profit meant to fight the election
results not about her completely
outrageous participation in perpetuating
the big lie with the frivolous bogus
legal challenges against it so it's
related to the insanity she was involved
in but it's actually about the financing
of that Insanity not the insanity itself
and of course she may face disbarment
and all sorts of other problems going
forward as well but it's about the
funding of those actions not the actions
themselves she seems quite troubled as a
reminder here was this very strange
interview that she did with um Sarah
Ferguson um we looked at this a couple
months ago let's get a few simple facts
straight yeah and how many states were
smartmatic machines and software used in
the 2020 election I don't even know the
exact numbers no idea but you were
making some
um big statements very dramatic critical
statements about smartmatic you must
have known what their involvement was in
the election oh you'd have to go look at
our complaint against with respect to
the four states that we file legal
complaints in right to get the details
of that a Google search would have shown
you that smartmatic was operating in one
single county in California oh I'm
saying I think their involvement's
probably a lot bigger than that what
research or fact checking did you do at
the time to find out what smartmatics
actual involvement in the election was
if you work for smartmatic
you've made an allegation against
smartmatic that they stole a
presidential election I think it's
incumbent on both of us to know what
smartmatic's involvement was it seems
like a pretty foundational fact I mean
I'm confused right now about why you're
here
because you how do you get into my house
ma'am series of
very strong allegations against
smartmatic and against Dominion
containing many eras of fact do you
accept the fact now that the company
that you accused of stealing a national
election only operated in one County in
LA in California one County one state no
I'm not prepared to accept that fact
I think smartmatics involvement was far
more significant than that do I think
they're trying to minimize their
involvement of course I do you said that
smartmatic owns Dominion how do you
justify such a basic factual error I'm
gonna stop this interview
so anyway who could have predicted that
this entire thing she got involved in
would have backfired horribly so now
under federal investigation and um I
mean I wonder if you ask or do you
regret even getting involved in this
stuff Trump abandoned you your legal
trouble Federal investigations
humiliating interviews my instinct is
she's not so deluded that uh she would
say no I it was all worth it my instinct
as she would say it wasn't worth it it
wasn't worth it but we may never know
we'll take a quick break and we will be
back right after this insane New
Revelations about covid during the last
presidential campaign involving Donald
Trump and Joe Biden incredible
incredible Revelations from Mark Meadows
stay with us it is an incred an insane
story but a completely predictable one
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show so it's
now being alleged that in that Infamous
debate between Donald Trump and Joe
Biden during the 2020 presidential
campaign shortly after which it was
officially announced that Donald Trump
had coveted it appears Trump actually
already had covet at the debate and knew
it now this is shocking in that Trump
would do something so irresponsible that
a president would allegedly hide a
diagnosis of a very contagious disease
and risk exposing his opponent it to the
disease it is shocking but it is not
surprising and we all suspected it at
the time that's the thing and we're
going to go back to some of those clips
um the report is in the guardian Trump
tested positive for covet a few days
before the debate Chief of Staff Mark
Meadow says in his new book
Mark Meadows makes a stunning admission
in his new Memoir obtained by the
guardian saying a second test returned
negative Donald Trump tested positive
for covid three days before his first
debate against Joe Biden there it is
Mark Meadows also writes that though he
knew each candidate was required to test
negative within 72 hours nothing was
going to stop Trump from going out there
Trump Meadow says in the book returned a
negative result from a different test
shortly after the positive in other
words Trump found a negative test
nonetheless the stunning revelation of
an unreported positive follows a year of
speculation about Trump then 74 had the
potentially deadly virus when he faced
Biden 77 in Cleveland on the 29th of
September remember Trump announced he
had covet on October 2nd the White House
said he announced the result within an
hour of receiving it and he later went
to the hospital
um Donald Trump is denying it Donald
Trump put out a statement saying the
story of me having coveted prior to her
during the first debate is fake news in
fact the tests revealed I did not have
coveted prior to the debate now this
could be a completely meaningless
statement and you just break it down
into its component parts and you have to
say well what how could what he be
saying maybe be
true but not the full truth when Trump
says the story of me having covid
is fake news he might be referring to
having symptomatic covet what he might
mean is listen before the debate I had a
positive test and a negative test but I
didn't have any symptoms and I didn't
really have it until later that's what
Trump might mean and he might be saying
that out of ignorance or we might be
saying it out of calculation Trump also
says a test revealed I didn't have covid
prior to the debate
right the story from Mark Meadows is he
got a positive test then he took a
different test and it was negative
and so a test revealed I didn't have
covid but one test revealed that you did
and of course we all suspected that this
was the case as a reminder it's like it
was yesterday we had this video when
Trump was in the hospital Dr Sean Conley
was asked when did Trump last test
negative and I watched this I think we
had a stream with 60 70 000 people
watching at the time we all watched it
together and his answer made me say and
it made many of you say that is an
evasive answer Trump clearly had coveted
during the Biden debate and he knew it
just as a reminder remember this tell us
when he had his last negative test was
it Thursday was it Wednesday when do you
remember when he had his last negative
text I don't want to go backwards uh
for people who are around him I
understand did the contact racing uh as
I understand it is being done uh I'm not
involved with that
um so yeah very very suspicious answer
that made all of us think that's
obviously a lie and then this is from
this morning on CNN Donald Trump tested
positive for Coronavirus three days
before his first debate against Joe
Biden the September 29 2020. the the
stunning Revelation is in a new book by
former white house chief of staff Mark
Meadows that was obtained by the
guardian a positive test the country
never knew about a positive test days
before he ultimately admitted to the
country that he had coveted and remember
he didn't look good or sound good during
that debate and many of you were saying
in the chat when we were streaming
something's wrong with Trump right now
this before attending event after event
after event with vulnerable people now
there was a negative test the same day
but it still raises all kinds of
questions about honesty and transparency
and timing and why the wildlife chose to
trust one test rather than another well
he trusted the test that said negative
obviously for the debate according to
the guardian Meadows writes that he knew
each candidate was required to test
negative for the virus within 72 hours
of the start time but quote nothing was
going to stop Trump from going out there
yeah you might also remember that when
Trump uh there was the story that Trump
Trump arrived too late to be tested but
on the honor System Trump's team said he
got a negative test today which may not
have been wrong may not have been a lie
but he also had had a positive test so I
mean listen irresponsible is an
understatement and there's the personal
and there's the administrative and
policy on policy Trump was a disaster on
kovid we have reports that had he taken
it more seriously not said 15 cases will
soon be zero talked about masks this you
know if he had if he had done all the
right things a significant number of the
deaths during 2020 could have been
prevented that we know at the policy
level
disbanded the pandemic response team you
guys know all the stories at this point
Trump also was behaving irresponsibly at
the personal level and we knew that
intuitively we knew that when Trump went
to a factory that requires masks wore no
mask but put on goggles that was weird
that was irresponsible uh we we saw all
the personal but this just adds yet
another layer to it and it is not
surprising because we all suspected it
at the time but it is shocking and this
is Trump's own former Chief of Staff
saying it Trump with a very strange and
narrowly worded denial I believe Mark
Meadows I don't think Mark Meadows would
make this up I don't know why Mark
Meadows would make this up and uh it it
was what we all suspected at the time
hey here is a bit of um this is sort of
like it's bad news in the sense of we
want presidents being briefed on on
intelligence matters but in a way it's
almost like good news and I'm going to
explain why in a second there's a new
report
that after the Riots of January 6th at
which point Donald Trump had two weeks
left as president he never got another
intelligence briefing after that he just
started rejecting the intelligence
briefings this is very very interesting
um the report from The Daily Beast is
that after a holiday break where he
didn't receive a classified Intel
briefing Trump was supposed to get one
on January 6 that's the day he incited
the riots and it didn't happen and then
he didn't get one for the rest of his
presidency and he hasn't gotten one
since remember former presidents are
entitled to get those briefings there
was this idea that maybe Joe Biden would
block Trump from getting future
briefings but as far as we know it has
not been done that unusual stretch where
the sitting president didn't receive a
regular classified briefing is recounted
in the latest version of the book
published and regularly revised by the
CIA which describes how spies update
presidents on National Security matters
the situation in the waning days of
Trump's presidency was so uncommon it
actually caused concern among some
Administration officials that Trump was
losing touch with reality as he was
getting unhinged advice on domestic
issues from justice department attorneys
and outside counsel that openly
advocated rejecting election results
One Source said to The Daily Beast there
was no certainty that he was getting
objective unbiased info in any other way
you couldn't trust that anybody around
him was able to get that information to
him in that period of time unlike past
presidents who would read their daily
intelligence report and get briefed
Trump regularly refused to read the text
demanded killer pictures and preferred
to get updated in person by his daily
briefer
um it all came to a halt in late 2020
and
um we talked a little bit about that
yesterday now I I want to be really
upfront with you guys
the country may have been better off by
Donald Trump not getting those briefings
after that period of time if he was
getting the briefings at that point when
he was completely triggered unhinged off
the rails trying to steal back the
election who knows what he might have
done with the information from the
briefings who knows where he might have
blabbed about information from the
briefings and this is so insane but in a
weird way it's almost slightly
reassuring that Trump wasn't being
briefed at the time now it's important
to remember as the article sort of
mentions he wasn't really getting much
in the way of briefings to begin with
for the majority of his presidency he
wasn't reading them former president you
know Obama Bush
they would get a multi-page briefing
mostly text and they would read it and
then they might have follow-up questions
for an in-person briefing Trump wasn't
reading it he uh had the briefing
reduced to a single page and that one
page by multiple reports half the page
was some kind of a picture chart or
graph and then there were like two to
three bullet points that's what it was
being reduced to and then he just wanted
people to talk to him sometimes with TVs
on in the background so he couldn't sit
through them but it's not obvious to me
that it's bad listen it's bad that you
have a president who can't sit through
and read something it's bad that you
have a president that doesn't care to be
briefed that's all bad given that it was
Trump specifically
um and given that even in the Oval
Office he spilled secrets from an ally
to a Russian spy recruiter to I guess
look Alpha in his mind
given Trump's emotional state in those
last two weeks of the presidency I'm
almost reassured by the fact that he was
not taking those daily briefings let me
know your thoughts but it is a very very
bizarre thing that hopefully will never
happen again but I fear unfortunately
that it will we have a voicemail number
that number is 219 to David P this is so
funny we have this uh viewer Jen from
Providence and she's called in a bunch
of times during live shows she is going
to be she has a Jewish friend
and Jen wants to know how am I supposed
to deal with a Jewish friend on
Christmas listen to this
hi David uh Jen from Providence I
actually have a non-political question
for you uh my best friend is Jewish uh
also named David and we've invited him
over for Christmas
uh do we get him a Christmas present
the confused and bewildered tone I I
just love oh so uh how do we go about
this are there certain things that we
should avoid I would avoid
um blaming him for the death of Jesus
maybe I think that would be something
appropriate to avoid
uh he's the first Jewish person I've
actually really personally known I grew
up in the South where they weren't
really there uh thanks I know this is
kind of weird and it's more of a Dear
Abby thing bye
oh man I uh okay so listen here's the
deal Jewish person is invited over for
Christmas if you're getting everybody
gifts maybe you get them a gift it's not
a big deal it's really not you know you
don't have to do anything special
um just
don't oh I I there's something so
endearing about like listen I don't want
I don't want to do this should I avoid
certain things I don't know maybe you
don't if you're saying some kind of
Christian grace before the meal maybe
you don't go to the Jewish friend I'm
not even really sure but I'm sure Jen
that it's gonna go great and uh also by
by the way a funny thing when people say
this is really the only Jewish person I
know or something I've never met a
Jewish person before
um almost always if you're an adult in
the United States even if you're from
the south what you mean is I wasn't
aware
of the Jewish people that I met because
it's not necessarily announced or
obvious
um uh and I I guess it's theoretically
possible that you could get through much
of life without ever meeting a Jewish
person but for the most part it's you
didn't know the person was Jewish
um it's sort of like you know what
someone says I don't even know oh you
know I'm colorblind really I've never
met anyone who's colorblind
colorblindness is common enough that you
probably did meet someone who's
colorblind but it just wasn't made a
topic of conversation I don't know if
that's a suitable analogy but Jen I
think you're gonna do great I really do
I think uh please report back and tell
us how it goes we have a great bonus
show for you today
um there is Major controversy building
about Kyle Rittenhouse and Arizona State
University and this started during the
trial and it has now blown up into
something much different and much bigger
we're going to talk about it on today's
bonus show we will also talk about a
federal appeals court upholding the
California ban on high-capacity firearm
magazines and what it means and whether
it's likely to remain and lastly we are
going to talk about the ex-officer who
killed Dante Wright this is the trial of
Kim Potter this is another trial that is
uh now going on we're going to talk
about it and it's not one we've talked
about as much so we will discuss that on
the bonus show so uh number one if you
want to listen to today's bonus show
watch the bonus show become a member at
joinpakman.com every weekday
we do another show for our members at
joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code felony21 to get a huge discount
it's such a large discount it should be
a felony but it's not it's just a
discount okay sign up at joinpackman.com
additionally December 14th now less than
two weeks away we will be doing our next
David packman show viewer Town Hall
it'll be at 6 PM Eastern streaming live
on our second YouTube channel that's
Pac-Man Live if you want to watch you're
welcome to watch if you want to call in
you're welcome to call in as well it's
wide open if you want priority during
the Collins get a membership at
joinpakman.com we will see you on the
bonus show and uh also back on
tomorrow's program
foreign
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors blinkist is the
app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person by letting you read
or listen to an entire non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes you can try it for
free and get 25 off a subscription by
going to blinkist.com David Pacman